e daí ele vai levar leva guilele ballet
ii
o olá boa tarde gostoso não é fernando
esteves está em seus no insta só as
director dos nossos livros novos rec a
investimentos e procura a diminuir um
bocadinho aos contrastes e nós temos
aqui a falar de contrastes os nossos
contraste ciclo entre a verdade ea
mentira pode comer quando me convidaram
para fazer a esta intervenção que segue
imediatamente diz é basicamente sobre
isso que eu falo e o trabalho todos os
dias onde é que está a verdade onde é
que está a mentira o que é que esse pa
pode ser que são as donas comuns não é
fácil de fazer vamos ser por partes a é
que estão a partida esse a mentira ea
verdade se tornarem iguais a esta é uma
das para mim uma das grandes perguntas
das sociedades modernas uma das grandes
perguntas da
e quando é que a mentira ea verdade
fornari buzz começar ia perguntar se
algum de vocês conhecem de jovem alguém
alguma vez viu uma fotografia deste
jovem nas redes sociais não este senhor
alguém ouviu alguma vez
e não ok então eles são jorge e onu
também são conhecidos como piá e tony
carvalho do facebook
e o tony carvalho do facebook um dia a
um tony carreira do facebook da
direction segundo folgado e um dia
decidiu fazer uma coisa que considerou
original civil a inventar um post na sua
página do facebook sobre um jovem a
jovem de ar que teria ganham concurso de
olimpíadas da física quântica no
estrangeiro tanta e rogério no entanto
em portugal ninguém sabia que ele tinha
ganhado ganhou porque nós somos um país
em que se dá a importância apenas ao
ronaldo ao marinho estas figuras passe
planetárias e não damos valor e o que é
nosso e ele está doente no posto para
bem estamos a falar de uma pessoa que
tem cerca de 300 amigos no facebook o
que que o em termos de escala é muito
pouco é muito limitado no entanto quando
ele deu conta da este posso já tinha
cerca de 20 mil cartilhas ou ela soube
que o exagerado verificou que já estava
assim
a falha no brasil é certa eu penso é bom
isso é apenas uma brincadeira a e a este
este jovem na realidade é o diabo é o
johnny é um ator pornográfico espanhol
esse caderno sabe dizer isso as pessoas
e começou nos comentários os comentários
oscilavam entre que país as porcarias
que nós temos como é possível
desprezaram desde jovens talentos como é
possível nós não temos construído quando
o francisco recentemente madura para dar
projeção a pessoas com qualidade que
avisar trabalharem precisarem no
interior não conseguem atingir a
relevância que outros com profissões que
não são obviamente nós mas são
diferentes a conseguem a ponta os outros
folgado com sua colocar comentários em
cima dos comentários dos seus dos seus
perigosos essas aqui por favor não
partirem mais isto esta notícia falsa
não faz com isso e as tuas continuavam a
partilhar até chegar aos 90 melhor para
os melhores continuar vou chegar por
onde lugar ficou obviamente quase louco
porque percebeu facilmente que não ah
não valia não interessava nada aquilo
que ele dizia as pessoas continuavam a
partilhar este porque porque as
partilhas são a moeda dos da mídia são
aquilo que faz que faz movimentar abrir
uma ver neste momento em cerca de dois
mil milhões de utilizadores nossa
partilhamos todos os dias em cada minuto
do mundo sobre as 72 horas de vídeo no
youtube
as fotos são 58 fotos partilhadas por
segundo no instagram 3500 fotos para
telas por segundo no facebook e
significa o quê que de fato nós
basicamente nas redes sociais
funcionários para dar prazer ao outro eu
partido eu vejo uma parte da sua a nós
somos amigos podemos ser amigos mesmo
entao amigos na maior parte das vezes
somos apenas amigos ainda ateu parte
sempre ou quase sempre na expectativa de
que a seguir também partir das mesmas
coisas parte das minhas coisas para ti
para darmos satisfação outro para os
estimados os nossos conteúdos e as
nossas opiniões hoje a a internet e as
redes sociais são uma coisa
absolutamente maravilhosa a por um
motivo muito simples até há pouco tempo
a opinião aí ó a expressão da opinião
livre e pública a visitá-la uma carta
eram safadão uma caixa só quem tinha
acesso
eu penso em modelagem slim é que poderia
dizer aquilo começava a sobre o mundo as
redes sociais vieram revolucionar isso
hoje qualquer um de nós pode ser
exatamente aquilo que a atenção sobre as
coisas problema a máxima liberdade que é
fenomenal não correspondeu a máxima
responsabilidade nós partilhamos é
criticamente e essa parte da crítica é
uma partida que a equipe é um grande
problema sínteses dos americanos já
admitiram ter partilhado uma informação
recebiam ser falsa olha isso é muito
grave e o nosso cérebro está formatados
para acreditar mesmo quando sabe que
está presente uma manipulação a existem
estudos que foram feitos segundo os
quais a nós perante uma informação que
nos chega por quarta redes sociais vai
ao encontro daquilo que nós
acreditássemos iremos que eu sou a 1
a extrema-direita e no meu mural do
facebook aparece uma informação segundo
o qual a um líder de extrema-direita
acaba de conseguir um feito a enorme em
termos internacionais ou aquela
apresentar uma tese de doutoramento
revolucionária de sete o partido em
diariamente eu não preciso aquele ser
impactado por que ela informação a
várias vezes para ti a partir para fazer
projeção se pelo contrário eu sou uma
pessoa a com mãe ficou convicções
contrárias aquele senhor eu preciso de
ser impactado por três times diferentes
para acreditar a inflação e
eventualmente partilhá-la funciona assim
estás pesado parabéns nós estamos
effecti vamente por uma tarde parte da
vejam ai este vídeo tempo voador
e esse senhor tem dois braços como todos
nós temos e depois tem o processo está a
ser perguntar por um senhor que ele sabe
alguém que não é dele não é eu já lavei
acontece
g1
e ele tirou então não esquerda porque
ele inconscientemente acreditou que o
senhor estava a dirigir à mão dele nós
estamos formatados para acreditar
inconscientemente nós temos comentários
para acreditar portanto princípio básico
quando ele chegar alguma coisa no
facebook das redes sociais a que nós
consideremos de alguma forma equívoca a
em seus duas vezes antes de antes de
partilhar vamos ler os conteúdos o maior
parte das pessoas não lê a os conteúdos
antes de partilhar um título eu tivesse
se eu tivesse esse dinheiro agora no
polígono os novos conteúdos estavam ser
partilhadas nós temos sempre uma
pergunta de partida e mas iremos a o
rendimento social inserção a eu não mal
utilizado pelas pessoas que têm fracos
curso e abusam da rendimento social de
inserção nós plantamos a pergunta e
depois verificar
e compartilhava os nossos povos e as
nossas dúvidas em forma de pergunta
editava disse assim claro estes tipos
são exploradores e depois aquilo era
partilhar a exaustão e nós concluímos
que estávamos também a contribuir em
voltar em mente para a disseminação de
fake news de desinformação o que não
fizeres recentemente foi reintroduzidos
nós estaremos com falso ou verdadeiro é
certa parte quem partilha que o já parte
com informação ao dizer isto é falso por
favor não partilha isso é muito
importante eles todos que ter muita
responsabilidade agora vamos passar um
novo nível imagine que essas partidas
chegam aos milhares numa viagem a seguir
a tocar dizer outro lote de esquina
a todos conhecemos max weber
e a mãe está lá duas pessoas são as
conhecemos são dois líderes mundiais
estão dois vídeos falsos são aquilo que
nós temos a diferente diferente são
vídeos construídos concurso a
inteligência artificial praticamente
perfeito estão a tecnologia ainda não
estava se ficar mas vai estar
massificada e a nova olhamos para o
alvará mei olhamos para o max a crer e
acreditar naquilo que eu estou a dizer
eficaz em contradição e as referências
universitário o dos acabar que foi que
foi foi por causa a circular embora a
mensagem não seja propriamente a
perturbadora mas isso quer dizer uma
coisa nós temos avançar claro metrô
cidade em que e voltamos a nossa a nossa
a nossa sempre densidade inicial nós
nunca tivemos tanta dificuldade em
seguir antes dele da desinfecção e isto
é muito grave faz com as consequências
partir do momento em que sim tal e se
instala aquilo que uma canjica brincar
a oab novadia não é mike classificou
como envelopes a altura em que a
informação ea ficção o flick tal forma
se atingir uma espécie de apocalipse
informativo em que as pessoas não são
capazes de distinguir uma imagem
verdadeira é uma imagem falsa imagine o
que é você estar em pranto um vídeo de
obama em que ele declara guerra a coreia
do norte vocês não sabem assim que leva
bem ou não que tipo de sociedade é que
nós vamos ter nessa altura quando vocês
vinham vídeo produzido pelo washington
post e outra produzido uma rede social
por um enorme e vocês não conseguem
perceber qual é que é verdade ou não nós
vamos deixar de acreditar nos dois
estamos o que estamos apáticos tão
descrentes dormem dislate vistas ficamos
um cadinho embriagado sem completamente
eu posso usar cada pincel tem nenhum de
vocês conhecia o gráfico que eu não
folgado mas eu acho que todos nós já
respondi já ficamos empregados que uma
vez pelo menos uma vez na vida mais ou
menos pronto uns mais e outros meses e
quantos anos empregado há sempre uma
coisa que temos a ferra o juízo o
raciocínio nós ficamos com pouca
capacidade para decidir decidimos mal
urbana alcides mal e ao termos uma
sociedade na qual não acreditar ficamos
muito permeáveis à mensagens contra o
sistema porque nós deixamos de acreditar
o sistema por possível de se obter
verdade e e mentiras e essa polarização
é importante para nos situarmos no mundo
e assim aparece uns um andré ventura em
portugal parece um donald trump que
também é de sistema bolsonaro também a
gente sistema um santiago abascal também
é o sal vir aparecem certas figuras e
elas apresentam-se uma mensagem que vai
ao encontro daquilo em que acreditamos
que é
em situações atuais a cidade tal qual a
ter já não é suficiente para nos
defender já não é suficiente isso você
ser absolutamente o idoso prato me
trazia a eu tenho que acabasse
ultrapassar o tempo mas não queria
deixar de deixar aqui algumas sagas
muito rápido o que é que nós podemos
fazer para prevenir o infocalipse
podemos nas frentes das plataformas
whatsapp podemos nos dirigir as partidas
limitação do número de grupos ou seja
quanto mais porque quanto mais limitados
na limitação se vemos é libertar
informação e-mail informação falsa
melhor é um começo não é não é uma
solução ideal mas é um começo trouxe lá
também no twitter podemos obviamente
também limitar a capacidade de para
criar cresce de forma artificial limitar
a capacidade para se criarem vozes de se
criarem perfis falsos filho condicionam
as discussões no dia pode ser nas
discussões nomeadamente de pedro litoral
e podem claramente
e os resultados da campanha eleitoral
donald trump provocam com a sua campanha
facebook muito rapidamente também
identificar e eliminar rapidamente falou
seus falsos limitar a capacidade por
isso não te fiz falsos não forçar a
sequência dos dados pessoais e depois
nós os média que até agora temos ali
enterrada cabeça dará olimpicamente
existem agora aumenta alguns esforços o
polígono é um esforço seguir ente
querido é um grão de areia no deserto
mas qualquer discussão mas é um ele é um
esforço está sendo publicado pelo mundo
todo nós temos que fazer mais quer dizer
que não se falou de players pois
trabalham então vai parece meio assim
tipo estar todos a combate por este bem
comum deve ter mais velocidade aproximar
mentira é mentira já dizia uma arte bem
funciona mais depressa dar uma volta ao
mundo do que é verdade calças rotas uma
mentira circula velocidade 50 vezes
superior uma verdade o que nós temos de
fazer a importar esta
se tornar é verdade mais rápida atingir
a mentir isto consegue-se através da
tecnologia mecanismos inteligência
artificial a combater mecanismos
inteligência artificial quanto mais
parece que nós estamos a mentir melhor e
a sua ir lá está a outra na lama do
camisa e mostrou os o teclado então um
site brasileiro que já o fez muito
distante um uns novos e um chamado aos
fatos período hubble chamado fátima a o
que é que o fátima faz a ele está aqui
está ligado uma bolsa de influenciadores
no twitter brasileiro e cada vez que um
dia se investigadores a de investigação
influenciadores evite no seu twitter uma
informação falsa que lida com aquilo que
é o arquivo de todas as informações que
já foram cercados pelos fatos que é um
jornal fé que ele vai se diariamente um
tweet para a página do emissor do do
twitter falso a dizer
oi oi explique você compartilhou é de
uma disse falsa ajuda a espalhar a
informação correta aqui e fini book a
partilha muito dificilmente nós vamos
fazer uma partida com este slime vai ser
muito difícil que passado e isto é
entediado lá está a velocidade não é
temos a calçar as botas mais depressa e
depois para terminar poderes também uma
vez mais e investir em inteligência
artificial olha só e vou acabar com isto
o que fizeram os mais de fé que a gente
vimos na última campanha eleitoral foi
apresento fizeram uma um vídeo a
concurso inteligente e inteligência
artificial tem que colocar os vários
candidatos a fazer a dar mensagens
pedagógicas sobre a não distribuição de
notícias falso ficou muito interessante
foi bem foi distribuir em massa na
vender e é já considerado o preço
estádio a nível mundial vejam lá e
e parabéns a mesmo para finalizar a isto
é um esforço para combater a mentira e
se for sem sede tem que ser estendidos a
que pertencer os cursos que seja a
explicação pertencer o esforço de todos
e cada um de nós porque democracia
algumas ligado a cioso para que deixamos
morrer para que deixemos morrer a um
klein a famoso do washington post que
diz assim crescia morte na escuridão eu
acho que todos nós somos responsáveis em
todos os dias em todas as nossas ações
fazer com que alguém me um pouco mais
obrigado a
oi oi oi oi